- You actually just
recently released a video,
whenever you were a
teenager, you were dancing?
- [Sterling] Oh.
- [Kelly] And I think,
I mean, can we see that?
- I can't believe this is on TV.
- What do we got, here we go, let me see.
- [Kelly] Yes, we like
to embarrass people.
- [Karen] Oh, this is, look at this!
(upbeat 90s pop music)
(laughs)
- Oh my god.
(snorts)
- Look at the seriousness in your face!
- Oh my god!
- You're slow, slow
(snorts)
- I thought I looked so good!
- [Sterling] Yes!
- [Karen] Look at this!
- Oh my god, I love you!
- Oh, oh...
- This is--
- Oh, it's painful.
- No, this video shows me
that we could be friends
because that, the shoulders.
(applause)
- That, you did.
- [Kelly] With the shoulder.
But wait, what is your,
so we saw your go-to dance moves.
- [Sterling] Yeah.
- [Karen] Yes.
- What are your go, she's
shoulders, what are you?
- Oh yes, join me in this.
- Oh, Lord, I mean, back in the day
it was probably about the cabbage patch.
- [Kelly] Yes!
- You know, you could
rock out to the wop or
something like that.
- The wop!
- Wait, I don't know what
these are.
- Do the running man.
- You have to show me.
- You wanna see one?
- Yeah!
(cheers)
- I'll do it if you try it with me?
- Okay, deal.
- Alright.
- Well now I just wanna join.
- You have on heels.
I wanna join!
- So the cabbage patch is this.
- Oh, I know the cabbage patch!
(cheers)
- Go round, go round, go round.
- That's it, that's it, you got it.
I would make you do the running
man but you have heels on.
- I can't do that.
- I don't want you to hurt yourself.
It's just like... (cheers)
- Oh, okay.
Simple, simple.
- That was good.
- Thank you.
- Oh my god!
- Cabbage patch.
- I know you get the body roll
Cabbage patch doll.
- while you're going in a circle.
I like the cabbage patch.
- Me too.